good day and welcome everyone i'm jack van horn
from the university of virginia please allow me
to welcome you to this edition of our 2020
2021 foundations of biomedical data science
seminar series this lecture is supported
by uva's integrated translational health
institute of virginia the uva brain institute
the college of arts and sciences the school
of data science and through a grant from the
national institutes of general medical sciences
it's my privilege and honor today to welcome
our speaker dr Satrajit Ghosh from the mcgovern
institute for brain research at massachusetts
institute of technology dr ghosh received his
bachelor of science degree with honors in computer
science from the national university of singapore
he then earned a phd in cognitive and
neural systems from boston university
dr Ghosh is principal research scientist at
the mcgovern institute for brain research
and an assistant professor of otolaryngology
at harvard university school of medicine
he directs the sensible intelligence group whose
research portfolio comprises projects on spoken
communication brain imaging and informatics to
address the gaps in scientific knowledge in three
different areas the neural basis and translational
applications of human spoken communication
machine learning approaches to precision
psychiatry and medicine and preserving
information for reproducible research he is
also the director of data models and integration
as part of the repronym project an nih p41
center for reproducible neuroimaging computation
finally amongst his many accomplishments dr gauche
is the co-pi of the dandy project a u.s brain
initiative data archiving effort for cellular
neurophysiology as well as one of the prime movers
of the nype open software development effort dr
Ghosh's lecture today is entitled the shifting
dunes of data and computation and as always we are
streaming this lecture live and for recording by
youtube if you are watching by youtube today thank
you so much for joining us and also if you are one
of our specially selected 2020 2021 biomedical
data science innovation lab participants you are
encouraged to submit your questions for dr Ghosh
by the chat feature in your zoom session i will
synthesize these questions and i'll ask them
on your behalf towards the end of the lecture
and with that welcome Satra thank you so
much for joining us we're really looking
forward to your lecture hey thank you jack it's
a pleasure to be here and before i move forward
i will want to acknowledge the efforts of so
many collaborators and members of the group
over the many years and i'm going to kind of span
a couple of decades of information today so i
want to thank all the people who have contributed
and influenced many of the things i have done and
we continue to do today we're also very grateful
for support from the national institute of health
uh support that we've received from the incf
over the years and also internal support from the
mcgovern institute neurotechnology fund as jack
mentioned our group kind of focuses on three broad
areas or branches of study we want to understand
the neurophysiology of human communication we want
to do applied machine learning especially in the
context of precision medicine and psychiatry and
we want to preserve knowledge through reproducible
research and other neuroinformatics approaches
but what i'm going to focus on broadly today
is in this brain imaging and analytics section
of our work and i wanted to start by simply
showing what we can do with a single subject today
this is not super complicated but we can look
at things at an individual level on a brain and
what you're looking at on the left is an inflated
brain it's like taking the brain and blowing it
up a little bit like a balloon uh so that you can
peer into the cracks and crevices uh or the gyra
and salsa of the brain and on the right is the
stimulus that the subject was seeing and we're
going to look at a real-time functional activation
as the person is looking at those stimuli
i should note that this video has been edited
to compress it into a very short time span
uh but it does follow uh the
patterns that you would expect to see
i wish i would play music for you at this point
and at this point in time the person is reading
this aloud in the scanner and as you may have
noticed there's there were some very specific
patterns of activity as they were watching these
different components of the tasks but we did not
quite start in the space where we could do this
easily we had questions around speech production
and scientific questions often need
specific data and tools so when we
started we were looking to build a model or a
neurocomputational model of speech production
and we were looking at how neuroimaging
could inform us to build such a model
and one of the papers we were looking at at
that point in time was something about the
computational side of neuroimaging this is from
katrin almonds who was looking at a standard
process at that time which was to take brains
and normalize or register them to each other
and when people did that what katrina did was
looked at broadband areas 17 and 18 parts of
visual cortex and said when you align
people using this normalization method
as you increase the number of overlapping brains
the number of voxels or pieces of the brain that
actually overlap across people starts diminishing
rather rapidly now this was important for us in
the context of us trying to study the speech motor
control system and so we took that kind of effort
onto the temporal lobe and asked the same kinds
of questions and demonstrated the same kinds of
things and this led us to the notion that we
couldn't be using the standard tools in use
at that time to try and understand how the speech
motor control system worked so painstakingly every
single individual was anatomically parcelated into
regions of interest that then we could relate from
one individual to another and study to understand
the functional architecture of speech motor
control in the brain what so on one hand we were
doing the science of trying to understand speech
motor control on the other hand this required
us developing probably our first set of tools
we created a matlab based interactive editor
that jason torvill and for those of you who do
brain imaging the t interval is the same as the
dkt in the dkt atlas that's distributed through
free surfer and alfonso nieto castanon who today
you might know as the lead developer of the khan
library at that time we created this matlab
interface for json to quickly parcelate and
quickly meant several hours of work on the right
you kind of see an operational flowchart and this
workflow seems rather straightforward and simple
you get scanner data you analyze it you take the
pre-processed data and you bifurcate that into a
couple of different analysis and this entire thing
created what we would call perhaps the first
batch processing system at that time for spm
spm's batch editor had not yet been built but it
also was a place and time when we were developing
things in matlab writing code in c and c plus
interacting with vtk and free surfer and putting
computational geometry into our tools and it gave
us a foray into creating a set of tools that helps
one answer specific questions when standard tools
are not possible it was also around that time that
you could get data but get data by having
it mailed to you and this is an example
of us requesting data from the fmri data
center and it was mailed to us in cds
that we could then load and take a look at the
world started changing about four or five years
later and one of the things that started happening
was an explosion of the set of tools packages and
algorithms that were available for neuroimaging
we saw an exponential growth in these packages
but they were also containing differences in
algorithms they made differences in assumptions
they ran on different platforms they had different
interfaces they often relied on different data
formats and for some of these tools so as the
space was growing the world of neuroimaging was
starting to ask the question could i use different
packages for different kinds of things and here's
an example on the right of a section in a paper
around fmri data pre-processing and you're already
starting to see that people are using a couple of
different packages to build together workflows and
pipelines to process such data it was also
around this time that data started getting
much more multimodal we were acquiring anatomical
images we're acquiring functional images we were
looking at diffusion images for looking at water
diffusion as a proxy for connectivity in the brain
around the same time the ecosystem around python
was growing for those of you who might consider
python a de facto thing today around that time
when we started building the nypi project we had
to put up this slide on introduction to computer
science and programming at mit being taught in
python to convince many people that python is a
real language that people should be using uh to
do scientific work and there was an incredible
community of people uh led by many people around
the world developing these scientific tools
in python and this is what led us to one of
the first tools we created that was distributed
widely called nypipe and the idea behind ip was
simple you had all these different packages what
we wanted to do was to collate those packages
under a single uniform python api so that the user
or the developer of the workflow software did not
have to learn how to call spm through matlab
or how to call a command line interface from
fsl or free surfer it all came as a uniform
standardized api that they could use this did not
mean that you had the luxury of not knowing what
those tools do but it just helped kind of putting
these tools together to construct workflows that
allowed you to mix and match things especially as
you're starting to get into multimodal data from
anatomy from functional data and the fusion data
you could also use this engine to distribute your
computation initially it was to workstations in
the lab at that time through ssh and later on it
became one of those things that you could run on
hbc clusters and chris gargolefsky was one
of the lead architects of making this happen
he was in boston for six months we released one
of the major versions first versions of nypi over
a one-week sprint that then i think changed the
landscape of some of the pipeline-based computing
that we see today nypipe is in use in
almost 88 countries today and it has
spurred the development of several packages
that rely on it and an entire new ecosystem
of tools and workflows that were spearheaded
very much by chris and oscar and the other chris
who's now helping maintain many of these different
pieces so this ecosystem is what we see today
but it started about 10 years back and it is at
that point in time 10 years back that we were
looking at various ways of accessing data software
openly also creating collaborations that were open
some of the online systems like github had just
come online and we were able to leverage some
of these things to accelerate uh the software or
the analytic collaborations that were happening
and it was also spearheaded by two other
things around that time the international
neuroinformatics coordinating facility or incf
created the neuroimaging data sharing task force
and the neuro bureau started collaborating
on creating an open space for scientists and
researchers to work together collaboratively
through brain hacks and other events
what was important at that time and this
was again looking at about ten years
uh nine to ten years back that we were
already starting to think about how to capture
information in a way that is reusable a few
weeks back i know marianne martone gave a talk
in this seminar series on fairness or
fair data and available digital objects
some of that started at this point in time we
were looking at how do we represent metadata
how do we develop methods to ensure
interoperability across different
tools and packages and how do we distribute
this in a way that it's reusable by others
and this started a project called
the newer imaging data model project
which involves many people over the years in
trying to structure information that's accessible
at various levels we built this specifically
relying on something called the provenance model
something that would allow us to increase our
trust in our data and results by knowing where
they came from the core technologies behind
this were one of the things that was written
in this cern document almost 21 years back at
that time by tim berners-lee in showing how one
could relate different pieces of information
on the web and this is the model that we are
using even today and it is increasingly becoming
clear that a lot of information that's coming
online needs to be connected and related to
each other provenance needs to be tracked so
neuroimaging the neuroimaging data model was one
of the starting pieces of this a key piece of this
was also about harmonization of information
at that point in time we were starting to get
access to thousands of brain mri images through
initiatives that were spearheaded by mike milham
at the child mind institute and cameron craddock
we got access to a lot of data this was made
available through an interactive interface where
one could search for data sets through different
aspects of phenotypic information and it could be
things like diagnosis this involved individuals
with adhd or autism or control subjects or
they could be looking at various other aspects
of phenotypes and this created what we at that
time called the open neuroimaging laboratory and
perhaps the earliest use of the word open neuro
although open euro today is a very different thing
it's a fantastic resource of data created by chris
and russ and others in distributing fmri data sets
the intent of creating a distribution like
meta search to be able to search through it
was not just accessing data or seeing what's
out there publicly it was also about creating
a community of people who would come together
to edit brain images uh collaboratively using a
browser-based platform and this was one of the
first forays into browser-based technologies
for collaborative work and this is something
that's continued on today by roberto and katia
and one could go in there collaboratively
edit a brain and then render a brain which
in this particular case is that of a black
rhinoceros but a lot of it was intended as
going across brains not just across species but
a lot of human brains from different projects
so this led to a lot of data coming online and
but the data came online in different ways and one
of the things that happened with an idm was as a
graph and a semantic web model it was partly seen
as fairly complex with no tools and technologies
to actually create the metadata or the needs
that would be or the descriptors that would
be required to express data in searchable form
on the other hand you had completely
unstructured pdfs which people are still
used to today you read through it you understand
what was distributed and then you go find it
the brain imaging data structure which
was formulated around this time in 2015
chose this middle ground of coming to a community
consensus about a file layout and organization
with consensus metadata it did not try to make it
rich with the linked data semantics that nydm does
but it provided something that was acceptable to a
large community and a set of technologies that the
community could understand and build towards
and i think it's a fantastic example of how
you want to think about tools in the context of
your audience as opposed to perhaps the complete
notion of technology developers that might be
needed to build an infrastructure around it
so i'll take the human connection project as an
example while here i'm saying it was primarily
unstructured data that you had to find and do
things with it ushered in a set of data that was
fantastic today that project has grown and will
be releasing even more data over the next year but
when it first started the primary data set that
was available was the young adult human connectome
project and in that data set which at that point
we were playing with had about 500 subjects
so that was already an a few orders of magnitude
larger than most data sets in people's labs
and this raised various kinds of challenges for us
one of the things we were interested in was to try
and understand whether resting state functional
data could be used to do better alignment of
individuals to each other remember very early on
i said one of the things not people normally did
was to take volumetric images and align
one brain to another or to a template
we found that to be difficult at least in
those early days and used region based analysis
to do things but anatomical regions while they
govern some aspects of functionality are not an
identical map for all aspects of functionality
at the macro scale level so resting state data
which literally involves somebody lying in a
scanner and you're monitoring their brain activity
as it spontaneously fluctuates over time provides
some amount of structure to the patterns that
emerge and this gives rise to specific types of
networks and our question was could we use this to
look at how two people are similar to each other
and we relied on some mathematical techniques
which creates this matrix of correspondences
now the human connectome project data allows us
to do this for every single individual here's an
example of looking at it for three individuals
they may have different regions in the brain that
relate similarly to each other but you can kind
of align them all together using a procrustes or
other types of transforms into a common space now
the challenge here was that the human connectom
project data released data that were about 90 000
rows or points and if you construct this matrix
that would be a 90 000 square matrix if you stored
the 90 000 square matrix on a computer it will as
a floating point number or a matrix of floating
point numbers that will take about 64 gigabytes of
ram at that point in time not every computer had
64 gigabytes of ram and if you couple this now
with 500 subjects worth of data you're getting
into a place where your standard computational
tools are no longer feasible to do some of these
things so we came up with various ways and
efficiencies to deal with that scale of data
and that changed the mindset of what computational
infrastructure we should be investing in even at
mit we were able to at that time think about ways
in which the future of computation were to evolve
and preempt the construction of our compute
cluster to leverage larger memory sizes
even though most people weren't really
solving problems that needed that much
and this was a big boost our benefit at that time
we were able to run this human connectome project
analysis where we aligned people to a common space
using functional architectures and this itself led
to a series of new ways of applying this kind
of embedding or alignment that was spearheaded
by a dear friend and colleague daniel margulis in
looking at gradients in the brain both within and
across species as a way of representing macro
scale gradients of information that go from
unimodal properties to heteromodal regions that
have now allowed people to look at this in the
context of various disorders looking at within
region gradients and kind of thinking about
how these gradients map onto different
aspects of behavior and cognition
well many samples were kind of useful one of
the things that we were still interested in
was going back to our understanding of human
communication physiology so we wanted to see
how a standard diagram in a textbook like the one
you see on the left maps on to actual human data
now it turns out that for most part these
diagrams are based on animal or other studies
and just looking at the auditory and visual
systems one might notice that one of the primary
differences are the different stages of brain
regions or layers that one goes through going
from the sensory organ so in the auditory system
the cochlea or the visual system the retina into
perhaps the first major thoroughfare in relation
to cortex the thalamus and the auditory system has
many more junctions whereas in the visual system
that has been compressed and a lot of computation
gets done in the retina itself we were interested
in trying to see if we can figure out this pathway
in vivo in humans uh using these technologies that
we had access to like mri turns out we couldn't
quite get there so instead we step back we still
dealt with the human system but using x-vivo
tissues and we were delighted to find a data
set that was available that involved mr imaging
uh of an ex vivo brain stem that goes all
the way from the brain stem up to thalamus
and these are some of the
images that come out from this
data set so on the top row is this x vivo data
set on the bottom row is kind of a standard
human connectome project three tesla scan of
the corresponding anatomy and as you might
be able to see in this display the incredible
richness of the data that comes from the x vivo
scans so we are we were happy to see that many
people were starting to put data out there that
they weren't intending to be used for the purposes
we use them for but by putting the data openly
out there we were able to reuse it for a project
that it wasn't originally necessarily created for
and here is looking at the diffusion
orientation distribution functions and again
a comparison on the left of the x vivo data and
on the right of the human connectome project data
this is truly an unfair comparison on the right
is an in vivo scan on the left is an x vivo scan
but i think it's very clear the structure and
the clarity that comes just from looking at
these orientation distribution functions on
the on the left relative to the in vivo scan
where we still have some ways to go to get to
the kind of clarity that the x-vivo scan provides
and this allowed kevin who was a grad student
in the group at that time to create a replica
of that textbook figure using the diffusion
data that we got from the xvo scan now for
those of you who do diffusion mr cryptography
there's a lot of noise in the signal so it's a
little difficult to necessarily trust everything
you see or get out of a diffusion cryptography
reconstruction so as a following step another grad
student and this is federico di martinez who's at
maastricht university in the netherlands his grad
student faro gilban kind of joined up with kevin
to say what can we do to kind of extend this even
further and what they did was leverage a couple of
public data sets the xvivo data set that we
were looking at the big brain data set which was
released from mcgill and eulek and in vivo mri
data at 70 that farook and federico had collected
at maastricht in creating a connection between the
postmodern mri the big brain and the in vivo mri
and this allowed us to look at test
retest reliability of the localization
of these functions across individuals and look at
different structures across test retests within
an individual on different experimental days now
this kind of work relied on many different new
techniques to be created including alignment
of brain data across in vivo and xvivo scans
it turned out when we initially did this work the
registration methods failed and farooq and kevin
had to go in and tweak those registration methods
to make this work you might also notice these were
at very different resolutions or scales so most
techniques were created not to address that large
discrepancies in resolution and were relying on
resolution being somewhat similar to be able to
align things to each other so this also required
a new set of tools and techniques to be generated
and looked at much more prospectively and closely
to see if these registrations work for people
but this was one of the things that this produced
and in addition whatever was generated as a
result of this was made publicly available
as open data and other compute resources
shifting gears a little bit in our group the other
thing that we started looking at around that time
was looking at mapping genetic information
through brain imaging data into some level of
clinical information and in this particular
case we were looking at schizophrenia
with collaborators kehan manglik who's now
at university of pittsburgh and joel sanchez
arahua who's now a grad student at princeton and
we were interested in seeing if by inserting an
end of phenotype so instead of going directly from
genetic data to the clinical state if we inserted
an endophenotype like brain imaging information
could we get an easier process to both uh learn
the mapping from genes to the diagnosis state or
also map brain regions back to genetic precursors
and we tested this by asking the question how well
could we predict uh the class uh the state of the
individual using these two different methods
so in one case we just went with a standard
mechanism like lasso or other machine learning
techniques that went from brain regions
to the classification stage in the other
case we used a probabilistic graphical model
to map the genes through the end
of phenotype to the disease state
and what we found was that the probabilistic
graphical model had very similar performance
to the standard machine learning technique the
difference being we it was much much sparser
just by the nature of the construction of the
model uh we also ran an independent validation
on some external data sets and that also showed
us that this model was doing pretty similarly
on data that it had never seen and it provides
back a marker back to the genetic information
now what was interesting at this time was this was
one of the earliest data sets that was available
through the genus consortium thanks to gabriella
and tracy that had a decent number of subjects
with brain imaging data and genetic information
we were able to constrain the genetic information
through other much larger scale studies like the
pgc study and were able to include different kinds
of phenotypic information to further regress out
variants in this sample but this led us to the
fact that over the years we saw this increasing
trend in multi-modal data sets coming into play
which requires new analytics new tools and
new ways of looking at and exploring the data
so what does the next generation data and compute
infrastructure look like one of the things that
people have access to now is a fairly large set of
data you have various biobank projects like the uk
biobank the genus project that i just mentioned
the abcd study that's collecting longitudinal
data across about 10 000 kids the healthy brain
network study that's also plans to track 10 000
kids uh and at this point in time is around 3600
uh samples or so the fcp indie project this is the
functional connectome project the open neuro
and the ongoing human connectome projects and
its extensions that are all giving rise to
a scale of data that's very different from
what people are used to in their labs and these
data excuse me are spanning multiple modalities
and allows for rich exploration and investigation
and this requires a slightly different way of
approaching things and for this reason we just
finished running the first iteration of the
abcd repronam course which was targeted at mixing
computational tools with exploring the abcd data
a similar course has been run by ariel rochem and
tal yarkoni for the last four years called neuro
academy which again focuses on these computational
tools that wouldn't be necessary to process these
scales of diverse and heterogeneous data and
large scale data that's coming online today
and then over the pandemic one of the fantastic
things that happened was neuromatch academy
which was an online school for computational
neuroscience trying to integrate computational
neuroscience techniques as well as giving students
an option to learn about the various tools and
resources that one has access to and this is some
of these are being coordinated through a platform
called neurostars which is an open platform
for questions and answers for the neuroscience
community run by the incf and i encourage
everybody to contribute and build this uh platform
and looking at and responding to questions that
people create alongside these large data sets
the next problem that kind of comes up is how
do i access this data and on that front one of
the projects that has been coming online over the
last five years or so is a project called datalab
and what datalab does is it gives you access to
a plethora of data across the planet uh through
a git like interface now git may be something
that you're unfamiliar with it's a version
control system and what datalab does is it turns
that to version control data and provide access
to information that otherwise would have been
difficult as is shown on the slide the amount of
data that you can access through datalab is about
268 terabytes today and this is growing at an
exponential rate most people probably don't have
space to download that scale of data onto their
hpc systems or clusters and this is what the
unique part about datalab is you don't need
to download 268 terabytes of data you can download
only the necessary bits that you need access to so
in some ways it provides an index to an incredible
assortment of data and allows you to search for
and get to pieces of data that you need for the
question that you have at hand and in case you
have a few petabytes of storage you could download
all the pieces of data and store it locally
alongside this access to data we are seeing
an incredible set of tools coming online
some of these are as old as that first slide
i showed spm fsl free surfer ants and aphny
have been around for a long time and continue
to be some of the key elements that are used
in neuroimaging analysis but there are also
a whole lot of tools coming online in the
machine learning space including nylon
which is built on top of scikit-learn
and the various kind of standard machine
learning modules of tensorflow pytorch and keras
on the neural imaging site itself we are changing
the ecosystem a little bit uh building new general
purpose tools like pydra as a new workflow
engine test kraken a new testing framework
uh neurodocker creating analysis environments for
docker and singularity uh and no-brainer which i
will talk about in a little bit of time a
brain dnn library and alongside these are
highly specialized other tools like uticonfor.com
conversion mri qc various of the night preps and
knife flows that are coming online there are
also specialized in interfaces being built
for analyzing certain types of data in this case
analyzing data from fmri studies where people
were watching movies and this is a project
spearheaded by talia arconi and alejandro de
la vega at university of texas austin and it's
building an online platform that allows you to
quickly select the kinds of questions that you
might want to ask of these data sets and create
an analysis module that you can then run on your
own cluster to get at results from those questions
alongside such a specialized interface there are
other ways of looking at literature and from guile
viroqua's lab one of the projects is neuroquery
which allows you to ask questions almost as if
you were asking someone a question and it will
take the entities or patents in the question
or the query and turn them into a brain map
indicating places or regions in the brain which
might have been responsive to those terms or
entities that were in the question and it will
link that brain map or the creation of that brain
map to the set of publications that were used
to create that brain map so allowing a rich
connection between a query and literature through
brain imaging coordinates and data so this brings
me to i mentioned no brainer earlier as a robust
and validated uh neural network tool suite and
this is a recent brain initiative project that
we're working on with a bunch of collaborators but
primarily it's being run through mit mass general
hospital and georgia state university with some
collaborations at nimh and outside of the states
the current state of affairs is as you have just
heard an explosion of public accessible data
there's all kinds of data coming online
there's also been an explosion of models uh
you have models being created for segmentation
uh behavior prediction connectomics diagnosis
and we are seeing a continued improvement in the
computational infrastructure that supports these
models however there are many challenges despite
all the data being available i would say that it's
still the tip of the imaging data iceberg there's
much more clinical data that's hidden in hospitals
also much of the open data have been anonymized
so they have gone through transformations which
make it easy to access data but are not realistic
enough necessarily in relation to data that you
might get straight off of a scanner many of the
models that are being distributed i would say
still lack a fair amount of fairness while code is
being made increasingly available the pre-trained
models are not now this is all changing
dynamically even right now you are getting
more models that come out but we're also seeing
a rush to creating models which don't necessarily
have robustness or validated across a very
large set of data sets and often these are
research products that are not engineered
for production or computational efficiency
so if you wanted to run some of these models on
the size and scale of some of the biobank data
they would take time and effort to do
so there's also limited consideration
of data bias in many cases and finally a lot
of underspecification is happening as we build
some of these models which limits the utility
of the models beyond the lab into real world
spaces so we have been building up this framework
called no-brainer to try and kind of address
some of these challenges and here's a couple of
examples uh that i would like to share with you
we've been building some base networks for image
segmentations and parcelation we'll move on
to time series processing and surface based
operations pretty soon we were able to show
that a brain extraction network trained on 10 000
scans could be quickly fine-tuned to provide an
improvement for meningioma segmentation by relying
on the initial network trained on the 10 000 scans
as opposed to training just on the meningioma
segmentation data together with colleagues at nimh
we've developed this bayesian model on network
to not only segment brains but also to give us a
measure of uncertainty which allows us to relate
information in a brain to the quality of the
image itself and this has allowed us to kind of
think about quality control or how to improve
the quality of public data sets right from the
get-go instead of every lab having to think and
re-evaluate quality whenever they download the
data but this comes at a little bit of a cost
in developing this project you need to understand
various aspects of infrastructure it is a python
library that part is straightforward but we are
also using data lab and open science framework
to distribute models and data and creating
containerized applications that one would need
to understand how to use containers to run and
use in their own centers and when we build these
resources we have access to a set of resources
here at mit that spans different kinds of hardware
and if somebody who had to come into the project
they would need to have some kind of background
to be able to deal with these different
architectures infrastructures and platforms
and be able to understand the data modalities
and infrastructure that deals with creating
such models using brain imaging data
and this is a challenge for us right now
getting a set of people who have the
knowledge that spans these domains is hard
and it's something that would have to change
at a fundamental level in how we think about
training individuals computationally
at universities and other places
in neuroscience one of the things we want
to be able to do is to move beyond a single
modality and get towards multi-scale and
monthly modal integration and this is changing
very rapidly here at least in the us and more
broadly across brain initiatives in the world
the u.s brain initiative has funded and supported
a large set of data archives to capture data from
subcellular resolution to the whole brainscape and
one of the projects we are lucky to be part of is
called dandy which we're treating as not just on
data archive but also hoping that it will change
the way people interact with data and with each
other uh in the research space so we call it a
collaboration space for cellular neurophysiology
projects the basic elements of dandy like any
other application is fairly straightforward
it's a web application that you can use to
browse various data sets but it uses standardized
descriptors which improves the fairness of data
being distributed through dandy we're relying
on things like neurodata without borders
bids and idm as standards that inform the data
coming into the archive which makes it easier
for people to reuse some of these things when
they download the data onto their own platforms
alongside the web applications we are running
a jupiter hub which is an analytic platform
making the providing the ability for people to
do computation very close to the data on the hub
over the last year we've grown from
about 2 terabytes to 13 terabytes of data
and this is currently on a little bit of an
exponential trajectory so i hope we would be able
to kind of think about as a community what kind
of data we should be preserving in the long term
we don't have an answer for that right
now now to reuse this data the data has
to be richly annotated with metadata and we're
working with various groups to try and do so
and people who are using this archive can
use various python clients to get a data
into and out of the archive now the reason we were
able to build this up fairly quickly was we were
relying on a set of open source technologies with
a view that many different kinds of people could
come and use data from this archive it could be
a hardware developer who says i want to make it
easy for people to submit data to dandy and
i'm going to put out data in a common format
or it could be a citizen scientist a high
school student or someone who comes and says
i want to learn more about neuroscience data and
this data is now accessible at their fingertips
on the archive and we have leveraged a lot of
key projects over that have been built by the
open source community open source and open science
community over the years that we have been able to
kind of click together or patch together to create
this archive and at this moment it has it has data
from four species it supports multimodal data from
intra and extracellular uh recordings optical data
mri optical coherence demography data microscopy
data immunostaining data and human e-cog data
it can support multi-session data and
it supports various kinds of behavioral
both manipulations and observations through
optogenetic pre-behaving or video data sets
as i said one of the key elements of any data
distribution today is getting information in and
this still remains a challenge for us we want
information that comes from the scientists or
the researcher to make the data more useful to
the consumer or the end user and the general
tagline i go with is if your lab burned down
would you have put enough metadata onto the
archive so that you can restart your lab with
the data that's living on the archive and this
requires a concentrated effort not just within
a lab but across a community to come out with
better standards for describing the data the
amount of metadata that's needed or necessary
to interpret the data is absolutely going to
be critical as we put these archives online
the other challenge that's happening is
the amount of data that's coming online
neuropixels is a probe that's inserted that
has about 960 channels over 10 millimeters you
can insert it at multiple regions in the brain
collect data and about a 13 hour recording of
data would be about a terabyte in space now if you
imagine and scale this up across labs doing such
studies the amount of raw data being generated
is going to soon explode and we will have to come
to think about how to preserve data and what
to preserve the data generation and processing
is increasing on a daily basis and you might be
looking at 10 terabytes per day of data across
labs all the way to microscopy where you might be
looking at hundreds of petabytes of data over time
this requires not just challenges to be addressed
in terms of standardization and descriptor
evolution but primarily around sustainability
how are we going to sustain that scale of data
transfer and storage are going to be equally
important things both locally and in the cloud
or across networks and how do you compute on such
data we are already saying that computing on some
of the data sets might need to happen very
close to the data as opposed to pulling the
data from wherever it is through a mechanism
like data lab and computing on it locally
and finally to be able to truly extract knowledge
we need data sets to be inter interoperable
in the sense that they have to have
sufficient metadata to be able to be
reused for other purposes at this point i think
the culture of sharing has evolved quite a well
but we are still expecting a lot of evolution
in the process of sharing data as soon as it's
generated collaborating with others in the
cloud or on data centers and then creating a
community of practice around the best practices
that would be required to distribute data to
compute on it and to evolve and coalesce into
well-validated workflows that might exist
and this kind of leads me to the last
section of of this talk a little bit of
forward looking as to what we might expect and
i'll go back to the work we do in our group
some of the things we are
interested in is the ability to
measure things about an individual to predict
outcome like treatment or behavioral trajectories
and to adjust how an individual might behave
through interventions or the way they do things
and be able to re-measure and this is kind of
a cycle what we are interested in is thinking
about trajectories across individuals that might
overlap diverge or change to certain states that
might cause illnesses but to be able to do this
we need both objective and subjective measures
now objective measures are growing on a daily
basis with various kinds of wearables and other
data sets that are coming online but this is
really about longitudinal data about an individual
and we might we are hoping that we can feed
this into some of our models and algorithms
that learn from the data to provide better or
more precise indicators to an individual or
their caregivers and this will require what many
people have said as deep longitudinal phenotyping
in fact this figure on the right is from
about five years back netapp a company that
specializes in storage was already thinking
about how the human body would give rise to
a large amount of data as time progresses and if
you now think of this as kind of longitudinal data
every single human is going to be producing scales
of data that you might not have been thinking
about previously and this might be brain images
and signals but it's also data from smartphones
and wearables the genetic data especially if you
can now consider transcriptomic and other types
of genetic transformations are exploding at a
rapid scale and size clinical records are more
accessible although there's lots of difficulties
in getting to them right now and then the word of
world of microbiomes is also changing
some of these scales of data as we speak
so how we preserve even our own individual
data is something we have to think about moving
forward not just institutional and structural
information that's stored in clinical centers
and one of the projects i really appreciate
in this space is something called
is a project called open humans which allows
storing your own data into a personal data store
and what this means is that you have control
over your data you decide who to give it to
you could donate it for research you could
do your own research or you could explore
things by yourself and i think it's a fantastic
model for us to consider as we move forward
in thinking about both privacy considerations
but also being able to aggregate large
amounts of data when we need to solve problems
and this will still require the kind of work that
we were doing in the neuroimaging data model but
the scale of all biomedical data we need to be
able to link extract search over information even
if the raw underlying data may not be accessible
we may need to compute over information in privacy
preserving ways as well so it's something to
keep in mind as we think about the scale of data
if we could do this maybe tomorrow well
maybe not tomorrow but maybe over a short
period of time we're able to ask questions
for specific disorders where there may not be
large amounts of data in these public
archives we might be able to develop
algorithms and tools that actually
operate on real data and takes care
of bias across data sets and this will require
access to data in a way and even open humans where
the model is fine would still require evolving to
the scale and tune of data that's coming online
and one of the projects in that space is called
the interplanetary file system it's a way of
distributing data across nodes and networks
in a way where data is not just stored in a
central archive or a central repository but gets
distributed to make certain aspects of data access
and distribution much more efficient now this may
not be a solution for all biomedical data tomorrow
but this is an architecture that one can think
about in thinking about both private data sets
public data sets and distributing data sets over
the planet the final thing i'm going to end with
is the need for education so on the left the
missing semester of your cs education is a
website at mit that teaches people about the
things that are not often taught in courses and
these are critical in the world of analytics and
data systems that exist today some of the things
that every student should or researchers should
know how to be able to do is to make their com
computation portable to be able to go from one
system to another to be able to transition from
one hardware architecture to another there
has to be a better way of doing debugging
the iterative process that's often involved
in many of the analytic tools especially deep
learning and other technologies requires us moving
or iterating on the problems faster we have to be
able to track provenance if we have to show people
what a model was trained on how well it can do
and metadata curation which is something
that's often ignored in most analytics places
needs to become a more concerted effort and a
systematic effort across researchers and labs
we have to be able to compute efficiently at the
scales of data we are seeing otherwise we will be
waiting for just computation to finish bias and
quality control are going to be essential with
the rate at which data are emerging a lot of data
are being put out there without quality control
and that's a good thing in my opinion however as a
community we need to be able to label or annotate
the data sets so that downstream users can decide
whether they want to use certain types of data
for all of the software and analytic tools testing
and reproducibility and validation are going to
become critical and for many domains where we
don't have ground truth available the community
kind of has to come together to establish best
practices or principles by which we evaluate
not just from looking at the result and whether it
aligns with our hypothesis but some more principle
mechanisms whether through computational modeling
or others to say that what we are observing as a
result of the analytics is actually what we
want to see and the scale of data is going
to parallel the scale of computing which will
go back to the kinds of tools and technologies
that a student or a researcher might need to learn
today to be able to deal with this explosion of
data that's happening with that i'm going to thank
you for your attention and i'm happy to take any
questions sasha thank you so much man you covered
a ton of ground that is really fantastic um
let me see couple of questions we have
one from a one of our viewers here
how do you quantify or mitigate uncertainty
when deploying machine learning techniques
in your data analytic quests are there confidence
intervals are those a big deal should we be
paying attention to those uh wonderful question
so i can say about one of the approaches we are
taking with bayesian neural networks which
as an inbuilt mechanism of that architecture
provides us access to entropy or uncertainty that
we can leverage so when it runs it kind of says
this is how certain i'm about what i'm telling
you now many of these things as one might know
could be confident about some things and we
haven't solved every problem with uncertainty
but at least using these bayesian neural networks
is one step of evaluating uncertainty that we
think can be useful in the short term one
thing that is super interesting about kind
of the story you just told is you know kind of
beginning with an effort i was involved with
moons ago where we were delivering data to people
on dvd and if you kind of think about that time
uh it was about the same time that like netflix
started to become popular and how did you get your
movie of the week from you know from netflix
well you ordered it and they delivered it on
on a media like a compact disc or or dvd and so it
wasn't unusual and we were very sensitive to the
fact that you know filling up somebody's ethernet
pipe with you know streaming neuroimaging data
would very often bring some networks to their
knees and so we actually specifically chose
that as a medium to act as kind of a governor
on the system right so that we didn't have
one a lot of people complaining at us that we you
know had basically having the investigators being
complained about that they crashed their
own internets about it uh at the same time
realizing that the the ability to stream
effectively that kind of data writ large was going
to be a real challenge and we just the technology
of the time wasn't equipped for it even netflix
wasn't equipped now we take that for granted right
we stream stuff to our phones you know sitting on
the on the bus or something um and so it that
the technologies continue to to move forward
and that is certainly something that we've seen in
neuroimaging with all the different approaches and
methodologies and services that that you mentioned
and you know things like this uh i hadn't heard of
the ipfs but you know you could imagine being able
to to do that and i'm also was intrigued by the um
the net app talking about uh the the netapp thing
of 665 terabytes worth of just individual data
that brought to mind the quantified self project
which was uh kind of popular a few years ago but
then linking into open humans if we all quantified
ourselves that would be and you know made that
data distributed distributable through ipfs
and had all these quantitative tools it would
really be quite an impressive amount of stuff
at our fingertips on demand when we wanted it
it would be quite impressive absolutely i i
thought you might get a kick out of that fmridc
uh slide over there jack it was uh it was
good you know it's interesting it was it was
pioneering for its time um but uh i i marvel at
what we started um because there's just been so
much work done in this area which is just so
remarkable and you just summarized it for us
and one of the things i will say is uh we are
not uh at the stage where everything can go
over the internet yet so i i know of a project
within the brain initiative cell census network
that sends data by tape drives because even the
internet is insufficient to send that data over
so they're collecting fluorescence micro
optical sectioning tomography or fmos data
which are close to a petabyte if you
collate all those tapes together and
that becomes almost impossible to send
over the internet today yeah um it's a
real challenge and we're going to have to
think very carefully about how we instead
of moving data to where the processing happens to
possibly take processing to where the data live
and and it has to be i think both of those things
which is why i'm excited about at least the
future of things like ipfs and again i think
whether that exact technology is what's adopted
i don't know the answer but i think the
concepts in that technology are really good
and we will see this kind of mixed
movement of either data or computation
in the future world of research analytics and if
that can indeed be coupled with the personal data
stores like open humans it just simply opens up
a scale and potential for human-oriented research
that i think would transform almost everything we
are doing around human research today well satra
gosh from the mcgovern institute of brain research
at mit uh thank you so much for sharing your work
with us and all of these exciting efforts um so
thankful to have you join us and um we will not
be having a uh data science seminar series next
friday first because of some other activities that
we're doing for our uh 2020 2021 um uh innovation
lab participants but uh we will be seeing you
again soon here in the future once again thank
you Satrajit everyone enjoy a great weekend